it looked like a hot iron skillet with
tomato sauce and some eggs that they
cracked in oh like
Shawn I'm trying to listen
[Music]
welcome back everyone to another lovely
episode of the careful boys today is a
special special episode because Joe
are we doing that right now yeah
we just said that we just talked about
that we had a 45 minute meeting brother
okay go ahead go ahead go ahead Joe Joe
has come
to us from
whales and England
okay I come bearing gifts from Trap you
know like people used to do that all the
time yes because like I've noticed that
back in the day it wasn't that easy to
get the thing right so when people came
like oh can you bring that snack back
I'm missing that snack so bad right not
even get [__] everything so that
magic of like I come bearing gifts yeah
it's kind of gone and plus everything's
made in China yeah everything's easy to
get it so I try to get things that don't
really exist here you guys fish and
chips yeah yeah and most of it is like
snacks you got the Jade seals well
that's good because the food sucks first
and foremost I give to you from the m s
Food Market it was like Target they have
a it's like Target out there it's really
cool okay that looks good all butter
Viennese milk chocolate dipped fingers
I made myself a coffee
[Music]
we like Joe oh look at this chocolate
dipped cookie
he just eats them all yeah we're like oh
I would love to try one yeah thank you
thanks mate
I want a [__] finger you should take
one I thought I said Vietnamese finger
for a second I got one of those right
over here we have a bourbon cream
biscuit oh chocolate do we have any tea
oh yeah oh I we do have tea I like that
the bottom is [__] chocolate too
that's pretty good I didn't prepare well
because I should have been British about
it it made you guys milk British tea bro
this tastes British it reminds me of
those cans with the lemon cream yeah
yeah yeah yeah no blue thing
well that butter is very nice
do you feel British
a little you're drinking tea
and the texture's so good bourbon cream
biscuits how did you know these were the
things to get wow
do you have an advisor to tell you the
truth
last minute we just went into the market
and started buying a bunch of [__] and
realized
I have to get you guys some stuff it's
very nice thank you did Hannah recommend
any of these yeah she started grabbing
things because she's like oh this is
different they're gonna like this and
she goes some of this [__] is the cheap
sniff but like this is the best one oh
good [__] good bourbon cream it's
like an English Oreo and this is
disgusting this is good yeah I think
yeah I like this
this will be interesting to do on camera
licorice black licorice
I'll try it you like black Liquors I
don't but I know but I'll eat it just to
taste I think it tastes like [__] but
even the smell is awful I hate black
liquor yeah we gotta we gotta do it
right yeah but we gotta try it all right
for the for the vid we gotta try it
then assorted black licorice who eats
this stuff we do grandmas British
grandmas oh white grandpa burnt Tire how
do you like it
does she like it does Hannah even like
that no but she said it's uh something
that old people absolutely love and we
should just do it on camera to give a
taste test look at this
look at this burnt tie dude people who
live too long
is this is this like a satirical food
that's probably like the [__] like my
mom likes my mom likes like [__]
dried this is [__] disgusting it's
disgusting bro yeah it's not like stinky
tofu disgusting sorry to make your mouth
water bark
yeah objectively not good nah do black
licorice is disgust
are we eating it yeah you got it I'm
eating it you got an idiot [__] dog
eater
farts not a little poo poo little
pomeranian would you like me to make
bucking sounds so it's easier to eat
all right this ain't the same I knew
that that was gonna be gross so so I I
brought this pack from Hawaii for you
guys
know that one so it's a chaser to wash
it down the Chaser thank you yes I never
understood why uh you didn't get the
what was the Jagermeister was so popular
because that's what this is oh my God
but there's a there's a there's a
British flag in the Hawaiian flag so I
figured it kind of kind of kind of same
dude this smells like [__] yeah
this one smells like a Chinese herbal
store
oh yeah you know what it's not as bad as
I thought it was gonna be but it just
like licorice bro try this one no Red
Liquors like Red Vines is the [__] it's
the best so Steve I got I got something
to wash it down for you too okay so I
was at the airport better than the other
one though right it's all trash and I
was like thinking this is good you and
Anthony you guys like to drink our
guests like to drink yep but
I feel like you can get all the same
stuff right you could get it all like
you know you could get good like a bad
mom a Heineken and you don't have to go
to [__] Germany for it
you could get a Corona and you don't
have to go to Mexico for it
because I said to the guy I was like I
don't drink tell me something that
Americans can't get
and he might be bullshitting but this is
for you guys to chase down your alcohol
but this is from a distillery in
Scotland I don't know so it's like you
could get the brand but not this
particular one so me and Ryan right
how's it going we do a thing every year
for Christmas time where we get each
other like some kind of of uh whiskey or
some kind of scotch and I got him the
balvini last year but it it was um not
this it was like something else
different I think he didn't [__] you
at all yeah wow because I don't know
alcohol so I can't I don't know how to
buy alcohol you know all right
balvini balvini you've never had it
before let's go it looks like a cool
bottle it's straight from the UK it's 43
alcohol damn dude that's strong my
favorite was the licorice I think
[Music]
yeah he said he loved it
hey let me just get some of those Peach
Wings over here yeah yeah you saw wine
ones he's more British come on huh yeah
I don't know what this is
okay here that one has less sugar in it
here's a biscuit you could taste it down
with
it's much yummier wow can I smell that
this is such garbage is it alcoholic no
no not that it says bourbon no burp
they're just bourbon cream biscuits it
smells good nice cheers Hey Ron Cheers
Cheers guys cheers the champ oh let's
just make cheers to the Chow here's to
the Champs
you're the champion
to the champ to the champ that's
actually good is it I like it I also
like whiskey flavor though you guys
could have the alcohol me and Ryan will
eat the peach rings and I'm gonna chase
it with more pizzas and then we ran out
of space in the in the in the in the
suitcase because I would have brought
more but I I uh and I gave Ryan a bunch
more thank you did you buy anything for
yourself nah I just don't believe in
snacks the way that you guys do and I
want you guys to have diabetes so dude
we're gonna pour this out into a two
liter bottle and then we're gonna tell
Anthony that we had drank it all
nothing for you Anthony I'm sorry he's
gonna yeah I got it for him he'll be
stoked you guys are like the only
drinkers here he'll be soaked on it and
yeah okay cool Hello is he a big [__]
guy uh no he's a he's a tequila guy like
me but but we like it all we like it all
really honestly
yeah that's my [__] so you know when you
go over there you don't buy nothing for
yourself not snacks but just anything at
all no I mean I travel so much now that
like it's just this thing where cities
start to blend into the same thing and
whatever I want I'll just get it there
and I don't really take it home is there
anything you look forward to get when
you're over there what do you mean like
like a shepherd's pie or is it or like a
restaurant a restaurant to eat
restaurants yeah yeah like what do you
like Indian food Indian food in the UK
it's something else bro yeah it's
another thing man I like this place
called dishoom I know Indians are gonna
like rag on it because it's not the
it's because it's more like it's more
like um like a fusion upscale like upper
version of it like there's like those
food like the good spots are like you
just walk into like those little food
halls yeah and then like those little
like a Banu type Place those are good
yeah yeah but the reason why I
specifically like dishoom is because
they have this chili chutney sauce they
have like certain specific dishes that
they have and then the whole um
Ambiance it feels like a like an old
school Great Gatsby species that's what
you want you can travel that way yeah
yeah it's like a whole feel into it yeah
yeah and then if you get diarrhea if
he's a bathroom right there perfect
Malaysian food out there is fire dude
next time we go I gotta I gotta take it
to the spot it's right next to the
Houston Station and I think it's called
like the Roti King and um
their bread is amazing it's like every
oh bro it's just like it's so good and
they punch it and they mash it up do
they have any good Malaysian food on
Valley or on Maine they tried yeah they
got some good stuff solid spots oh I
want a lot more out of business I went
to one next to the barbershop
it was on Valley and close to Fremont
you know what I'm talking about I think
I know like I said you spot right um I
went to go get a haircut and then uh I
had like an hour wait so I'll say is
there anywhere to eat around here oh
there's some like Malaysian or whatever
things I walked there and as soon as I
walked in I was like oh [__] this place
smells like [__] but I was already there
like this oh
and then I asked them what should I
order and he's like oh everyone gets
this what'd you order I forgot it was
like some noodles and then I got some
like like nine day old pork or something
I don't know it was not good though
there was that one chain that tried to
open up we're gonna get this restaurant
shut down
there was a Malaysian there's a
Malaysian chain that tried to open here
it's pretty good that I forgot this is
the place you always sent me you always
sent me some some spot but there was
that Singaporean thing it said it said
Singaporean Cuisine but I didn't I've
never been there yeah but it's on
totally missed the mark they didn't it's
not the same like quality is not the
same from Malaysia it just doesn't taste
anything close to it but I've been to
the location in Malaysia yeah and then
so they try to open right here Monterey
Park and uh uh Atlantic and they they
didn't the one in the plaza yeah it
failed yeah yeah that one was pretty
solid that was pretty solid for a little
bit but then it's gone damn like before
pandemic oh you know what you're right
because when it first opened it was
there are chefs from Malaysia yeah and
then they they laughed oh they probably
trained other dudes yeah and then they
couldn't get it right there was actually
two spots on Atlantic that was pretty
solid won by kalimantan
it was like it was like a Malay spot
that one closed down now it's the
Shinsengumi or whatever and then the one
by uh by the movie theater but in the
thing is I think um there's just so many
different options that we have from the
West Coast so like
there like dude I had this Turkish
breakfast that [__] was fire man what's
what's in a Turkish breakfast so they
had this one dish it was like
it looked like a hot iron skillet with
tomato sauce and some eggs that they
cracked in oh like this
Sean I'm trying to
lift your [__] mouth shut up
imagine like just the pizza with no
bread like the tomato sauce and then you
get egg and then you just use that so
it's a deconstructed Pizza basically and
like vegetables roasted tomatoes yeah
and then you just dip you just dip into
it it's really easy to make too with
their Arabic bread it's like pita bread
but thinner so this is like that pizza
dip I sent you guys
yeah it's it's like that it's so [__]
good and then um Hannah had like some
some hummus like yogurt thing and like
you know it was it was pretty funny for
people watching right so my my folks
in-laws like my fake parents they're
going to the UK this month okay like
around the 15th where would Hannah
recommend they go if they're going to UK
for the first time
I think it depends on what they like
because like if you like the whole
castle [__] like I heard that you know
there's a ton like outside uh around
Scotland all that
um so I spent most of my time in Wales
and Liverpool Wales is a different
country yeah did you know that it's a
kingdom it's completely different is it
like Taiwan is it like how taiwan's a
country or yeah no no it's where no it's
uh depends
when I was a kid someone asked me a
country outside California
pretty much is a country at this point
John Cena told me that it's not a
country
if you're in Wales you gotta like say
sire and [__] no I was in Wales for like
you say my Lord like five days or
something and then I was in Liverpool
for like the rest and then I was in
London for a day so I got to catch up
with the with a friend of mine in London
but like so most of my time previously
like before I left London to go to all
these other places my idea of England
was just London which is wrong yeah it's
like if someone came to the U.S and
they've only been in New York they
didn't really go to the US they just
been to New York it's very true yeah
pretty good though it is pretty good
because there's everything here good
honestly but London I was like oh yeah
London doesn't feel that different from
the states and then I went to Wales and
then I went to like like they call it
North how different does it feel though
does it like comparatively New York to
what here would be the relative what
would be the relative difference I would
say Cardiff
felt like maybe Seattle but way less
popular that's very different right New
York to Seattle yeah it's about the same
I've been to both places better
transportation well the Space Needle
over here
and Liverpool better than public transit
yeah dude don't don't look it up that's
fine
just just trust me just trust me just
trust me you wouldn't know you wouldn't
know do people from Wales have their own
passport like that no it's still a
British passport oh because they're
still British right but then the
difference is in Wales everything it's
like Montreal or like Canada where they
have English and French over there
everything is Welsh and English
everywhere everywhere and then they say
everything in English and in Welsh can
you understand a heavy Welsh accent now
I can but it's still [__] hard do you
know any Welsh words oh no just like
cities I guess people should make
something up right now we don't go oh
yeah
so fast I think there's there's a I
might butcher this but kangolflin
phonetics do they speak Gaelic it is
Gaelic it's it's like so there's
Scottish Gaelic Welsh Gaelic and then
there's uh Irish and Liverpool they say
you won't
yeah Liverpool was like
we were in Liverpool and then I was like
um standing next to a group of folks and
I was asking Hannah I was like are they
speaking Gaelic and she goes no they're
just scousers
and they're like oh that means no I
don't know what that means like like
Patty the Baddie they're just
Northerners yeah do they hear him
talking about the Tories and they say
[__] the tourists
Liverpool looks like Gotham City oh
really it's like imagine if it's Hawaii
Vibes oh that's Gotham City
crime everywhere
but the city just looks like this old
ass place with like these crazy ass
buildings that are just I mean a lot of
European cities look like that right
other volcanoes
imagine if like a bunch of small town
villagers came into a like a city like
L.A so they still have this like you
know when you go into a village everyone
talks to each other right yeah so
they'll give they'll do full-on oh so
you have Village Vibes but in an urban
exactly so everyone talks to each other
and that's why that's why I was like
this is why Patty the Baddie came from
here like you could tell like it's all
these blue collared like working class
white folks that are like it's like
Alphabet City or like Bronx or something
huh and it's very Hawaiian the way where
like dudes will just throw down and
handle their [__] and they'll be on
their merry way you know and if people
still talk to each other off like
strangers talk to each other they're all
friendly they're always chatting [__]
when you say like how you doing like
they're really asking you like you know
over here it's like oh you're doing oh
good okay and you're just like yeah they
don't even start with how you're doing
bro like I was in the elevator and um
hemorrhoids
they don't even start and start you do
it we're we're in a where they start mid
conversations as if they already knew
each other it was the most bizarre [__]
ever so like I'm in the elevator with
Hannah and then the front desk lady was
inside they talk about the weather all
this another lady joins and then a
transgender lady comes in and they all
talk like they've been best friends
since like high school anymore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know how everyone says like oh oh we
come from a friendly City yeah and I was
like oh wait no no one really I've been
to a lot of places in the world and
there are friendly people yeah but Texas
Liver Liverpool's even one up friendlier
than anything I've ever witnessed
interesting more than Maine dude it's
crazy because it's an extrovert friendly
because there are friendly places but
it's like a very extroverted friendly
level because like so so me and my
family right we were looking at this big
heart sign and we're just looking at it
or like you want to take a picture oh no
and then this couple comes up to us
right
and then they're like you guys should
take a picture you know what you want to
do it we'll take the picture for you and
I was like damn this is weird but it's
weird I don't know they're like where
are you guys from you know and then like
and then I just give them the camera
we're taking photos and I was like when
is the sale coming what are they trying
to pitch
you wanna saw my mixtape
it was like it was like what are they
gonna ask for what are they gonna try to
sell that's how I kept feeling right but
they're good no we're just having a
conversation and I'm all like oh they
want a picture and then and then I was
like you guys want a picture and they're
like oh yeah sure like they didn't even
think about it right and then I find I
thought they were a couple but it was
like a gay best friend and his homegirl
they were out for a night of drinks and
then so I'm like understanding their
Dynamic their friendship all that [__]
and then we go off and I was like this
is normal and Hannah's like I mean I can
assume once you get us around our female
besties we become like the most yeah
active like vibrant talkative humans
unexistent yeah but it I mean but beyond
that I've witnessed this just with
everybody and Hannah says that's just
the way it is she says it was horrible
being an introvert in that she's not
that yeah but I think that's why she's
so sociable as an introvert yeah
yeah she could talk to anybody she said
there's a there's a time where literally
like she got out of a train station
right she asked this girl for like
directions or something the girl walked
her to where she was going and ended up
[__] being friends with her drinking
all night together and [__] that's kind
of tough that girl has no life exactly
no I don't want to drink with you but
they're just hella friendly like that
and I'll and everyone just talks to each
other like full-on conversations that's
so not like where we grew up you know
exactly so it's small town but like in a
major city with skyscrapers and all that
stuff with a lot of people so when
someone's doing that to Hannah and she's
like an introvert is she kind of like
boy
no like I seen another I saw another
element out there
international sign dude no she just goes
on in she just does her thing they just
go chat chat chat chat chat and I'm just
sitting there like oh [__] that's crazy
she need to go Like an Oxygen Bar after
or something
that was fucking's raining
that lad chats a lot of [__] and and
they dress super loud
they're like bright pink and like super
um
it's almost like they're all like going
to a rap concert but they're not into
hip-hop
I know exactly what you mean right it's
like leopard print pink and like it's
almost like trash Queens but you know
it's not high fashion trash plants he
likes the trash I do I like the trashy
but it's hard to explain bro it's not
even like it's not like high class High
fashion yeah it's just that's like
Jersey Shore [__] I like exactly I
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah super
everything bright colors yeah cool and
it's just a big loud
City you know yeah it's pretty
interesting so you'd recommend visiting
if you're that Personality yeah and I
think um it's kind of like Vegas in a
way where there's like a bar in every
[__] corner and so a lot of people
dude yeah they're just drunk all the
time social culture does it have its own
airport Liverpool or you gotta like fly
to London and then take a train or
something yeah there I think they have
an airport close by but I mean the train
ride from London's only a couple hours
oh like two or three or something but
yeah but not it was it was a good
experience I love the city and I'm like
I'm glad your family lives here because
then I couldn't see myself like being
here longer periods and it's not a
boring Place Cardiff was kind of boring
what was in there nothing no it just
felt like covet was still happening how
many of you guys are on Cardiff what was
Cardiff describe the boring Place hurray
her family lives there in wells and in
and in Liverpool but like the way that
the Cardiff City is is shaped though
what's cool is like imagine going down
Third Street Promenade and at the very
end there's a [__] castle like a
full-on malt in a [__] wall and then
you can go through we did a whole Castle
tour yeah so that's that was the cool
it's like a Citadel Outlet yeah yeah off
the fire freeway Factory there's some
there's some privately owned castles
yeah buy one get one
well thanks for all the [__] Joe yeah
hey get these before they're gone boys
foreign